this morning in our Saturday session a
return visit from Jason is full both
this program and the top of the music
charts are familiar territory for him
his brand-new collection reunions just
hit number one on four Billboard charts
including rock country and total album
sales he'll perform some of that new
music in just a moment but first our
Anthony Mason caught up with s Bowl on
their farm outside Nashville jason is
bolt and his wife the musician Amanda
shires have been hunkering down at home
with their four-year-old daughter merci
during the pandemic is bull was supposed
to tour behind his new album closed
session here's the barn instead he's
been performing his new music in their
bar
but every kid in cut-offs could be
mentally are you finding this
challenging at all yes it is challenging
fortunately for me you know since I got
sober eight and a half years ago I have
been working on the principle of process
and trying to stay in the moment and
trying to live one day at a time as they
say in AAA and turns out that was a
pretty good way to live through
something like this his bull recorded
his new album before the corona virus
outbreak
[Music]
but songs like what have I done to help
have a new meaning now
[Music]
tell me a little bit about that song it
really just came from the very literally
thought literal thought of what am i
doing to make the world a better place
that's not self-serving and is there
really anything that is keeping me from
trying harder I roll the baby while
recording reunions the songwriter whose
last two albums both went to number ones
on the country and rock charts says he
put pressure on himself
to live up to his own reputation this
was a hard record for you mate yeah it
was I've had a hard time admitting to
myself that I was under pressure you
know it always seemed to me like it's a
ridiculous reason to feel stress like oh
you have to make a good album because
your last album was good just sounds
like nonsense to me you know why do you
think you were putting that pressure
right that's a good question because I
thought well this is the only thing that
really matters in my life anyway is how
good I am at writing songs and making
records and touring and playing oh now I
don't I don't feel that way cuz I've got
a wife and a daughter and you know those
things are more important to me than my
work
his bow has appreciated being home with
his wife and daughter the past two
months but he does miss touring I think
what are the reason people are getting a
little grumpiest because no one really
has an idea how long it's gonna last
yeah it's kind of like you're in a in a
really really low security prison and
you just don't know when they're gonna
let yeah one day they're just gonna
knock on the door and say you can go now
you know in the meantime you can cook
for yourself watch Netflix and FaceTime
with your friends but it's still prison